hey everyone welcome back to games lost
III 2019 coverage I'm like my Hardy here
with Lucy James hello and we are joined
by the team working on dying light too
we have created with director Adrian yep
and narrative designer Chris Avalon how
are we doing guys thank you how are you
good
it's uh the show's been busy but
obviously you guys know that yeah so
tell us what you're showing this year
that you didn't last year what's like
the what are people excited about with
dying light - so basically today we have
a demo that shows everything that was
actually in a premise we lost here so
the choices and consequences that the
story beats that are really influenced
the gameplay and the gameplay that
influenced the story so it's all in our
brilliant demo and that's the thing we
bring the key message is that we are we
playing us Eden cold low so that is new
thing about the game this is an infected
guy who is in a in a city where
everyone's been infected and he's
looking for salvation his moral compass
is actually a player smaller a compass
so Euratom is a different day than in my
day didn't so that's the idea for for
our game the second thing is the release
window we introduced it with its spring
2020 the fact that Eden is infected is
that affecting not just like story and
gameplay are you talking much about that
yet we're not not talking about that
much right now it's for sure what I can
say the night time for Aiden is an
opportunity okay and as opposed to like
the first game where I was just utterly
terrifying there isn't part of what it
feels like horror but you it's when you
make a mistake during the night if
you're not making a mistake it's a huge
opportunity for Aiden gotcha
it's so the thing you've been talking a
lot about is the choices and
consequences which playing devil's
advocate I think sometimes that's a
buzzword before a game comes out you're
like oh yeah there's there's going to be
meaningful choices but oftentimes you
really look at it's like those choices
were kind of a facade right like not all
the time particularly with games you've
worked on so that's I think why people
are excited for this one um can you dive
into how those will work once we
actually get our hands on the game
well there's a few things I will try
with you is coming through all right so
there's a number of different endings
that you can bet you can experience it's
not just all funneled towards one ending
and also one thing that really drew me
to buying like two is it's not just the
reactivity the NPC's of the environment
environmental reactivity like sometimes
some of the choices you make will open
up brand-new game maps and other players
may not experience which ends up being a
huge awesome thing and Co off because if
you go visit someone else's City and
co-op you get to see those other spaces
data and laugh and their choices and
then start talking about all those
things came about but we think that's
what makes a really good reactive game
so it's not just like branching it's not
just a choice between two quest givers
so to speak it's something the world
will actually react it open up and close
in the word is actually a character in
our game so it's like it's it's an Eden
and the work you know so everything you
do influence the work and be in the
pre-production you are looking for the
the way we're gonna execute these
choices and consequences in dying lied
to and for sure I think that one was an
action game so we're trying to get this
this flow of choices the consequences in
the action game so there's not so much
you know thinking it's very natural it's
like you need to go A or B so you
deciding a be any going naturally in the
in the direction you want and you can
predict the consequence of that but not
all of them there's still something
that's happening who I can really live
you know you can see like I'm going that
way but something's gonna happen and you
need to live with those consequences so
that's a the part of our our idea yeah
chasing consequences and I think that's
honestly when you were talking about you
know every action having this reaction I
think that's what I love most about the
first dying light is that the way that
you were leveling up in the game was a
direct consequence of how you were
playing and it sounds like that's gonna
feed again now into the world and so it
just creates this incredible loop yeah
the cool thing about that is in deine
great wander still five hundred thousand
unique players every week playing and
we're talking with them and there are
crazy stories about where you are
I'm in the middle of the game lap four
or lap five so then playing it
constantly all over again
you know so in that like - they'll have
an opportunity to play again but it will
be different game for them because of
the choices consequences when you finish
in the game you actually cannot see you
won't see even 50% of the content so
therefore it creates a huge huge replay
ability for those players that will play
again they've gone a different they're
gonna do a different path different
choices and then they're gonna have a
different work and eventually if you
join others game that for example I'm
playing my game and the joining a crease
game please my different choices so I'm
gonna see different world because I'm
joining a session so it's also a very
great great social element of the game
where people can talk inside again about
they words how their words are looking
just a few seconds ago we're seeing the
player character discover landmarks
through binoculars seems a bit more
organic not just like seeing a point on
a map maybe maybe you can but in that
regard they weren't is there a is there
an effort to make like exploration more
organic as well excuse me is there like
an effort to make exploration feel more
natural as you're exploring the city
yeah we we actually attacked our mission
is to create the immersive experience
that's what we pick up the first person
camera as a something that it's similar
for every other games so we are diving
into this area even more so we have
those interactive objects that a lot of
them in the in the word that you can
open push move forward and then I'll
find something so it's a lot of those
kind of things in the game because we're
really aiming for immersive experience
binoculars is of course the tool that's
helping you in exploration on this
further distance that you can see zoom
and find something and eventually check
what's happening because discovering
Cobb just discovering things in opera
game is crucial the first game was set
in Iran and now we're looking second
game is kind of set in more more Eastern
European if you talk more about the
influences for we're dying like two is
set and what that brings to the game you
mean does the work the world yeah well
it's an European city or we put there a
lot of things from different cities
because
it's a monument of the civilization that
is gone so we wanted to make feel that
people will feel that it's it's a
familiar place the sensation of lost
shame which is everywhere you're gonna
see a burnt churches museums the car
saloons were super electric vehicles
that are useless right now so because of
that we just create a ultra Universal
version of the European city that it's
similar for everyone in a working so
that was our idea and on top of this
monument on top of the ruins of the
syllabication
we can see the new things that are
rising on the rooftop so that's also a
part of our vision of the of the world
so the new city is built on on the ruins
of the of the old one Chris you've
written a lot of different in a lot of
different genres but in particular some
of the stories I remember particularly
like New Vegas or something stuff like
that like post-apocalyptic I'm curious
what is it that draws you to that kind
of story and is there anything new
you're trying to tackle narratively and
dying light too that you haven't before
so post-apocalyptic it's just some of
the stories that I've worked on I happen
to enjoy that genre it's what's one of
several but in dying away what I like is
the pressure of the infection always
bearing down on you I not just you as
the player character but everyone you
mean the enviros is sort of struggling
with this disease and trying to find a
cure for this condition and it factors
into so many of their motivations and
it's sort of asked to make you appraise
people you meet and figure out what they
really want out of you because it can be
a really desperate situation with
regards to kind of the resurgence of
zombies in the last few years how do you
kind of craft a new story in that space
because I mean I was healing zombies
prolific in movies comments games now
well I think I like that's a really good
divide just when the theme of the game
itself and I might and a divided as much
as the zombies like completely go nuts
at night it's a very terrifying
experience the aspect of the humans
during the daytime presents or more of a
psychological social well you know as
bad as fighting the in fact
are and how lethal they are human beings
can be just as bad and they have many
different ways of making your life
miserable so the balance of that flood I
think that's up being pretty interesting
yep
yes funny Lucy mentioned the like recent
years has seen this resurgence of zombie
games or just Sambi fiction in general
but tech lines been there for how long
since you know Dead Island right like
what is it about zombies that attract
you as a studio you said your mission is
to make these immersive games while your
first person but it's often zombies what
is what is it about them that's so
interesting to you as a video game
developer specifically well the answer
will be very short we've been a huge fan
so Robert Kirkman comic books we've been
talking with this guy before the show
was done by AMC yeah and yeah and with
that that was the trigger yeah so we've
been fans of the the zombies in the way
or forever case fictional comics what is
really the walking desire option those
humans now those zombies yeah so we are
experimenting on that and we are where
we are right now we're going even
further with this with this idea delight
was and still is being supported and as
you said earlier has such a rabid
community but still loving the game and
still playing it how are you you know
developing new things for them you know
like trying to create something new for
dying like - that will subvert their
expectations while keeping core to what
they love about the original game I
can't tell you too much about that but
we've been not prepared so that you know
blast after dying like one we didn't
prepare like we should have something
for players for the first year maybe
maybe year and a half yeah but you know
as I mentioned before 500,000 people are
still playing dialog one and it's 2015
game so we were not prepared right now
we are sure that this being gonna work
and this choice and there's consequences
after gives a additional level for that
because every time you play the game
from the very beginning this different
game but on top of that we be planning
something further you know for a game to
make it living given even more than that
one
I can't tell you too much about that
when it comes to co-op how does that
change how you're approaching like the I
mean I like I know you said narrative
Lee in world-building wise you can find
another players world has just evolved
differently than yours and opened up
different choices yeah that's super cool
I'm curious like in terms of like the
moment-to-moment gameplay did you ever
have to make any adjustments to that to
account for co-op not so big changes
between what we had in dying light one
it works so there are not so and in
momentum and game production no changes
it's just working it's not a game about
numbers you know like level 50 weapon
and level 2 weapon how to mix up you
know so it's more tactical combat
integrate 1 there's still parameters of
the weapon but it's more about you know
how you use your thumb sticks and how to
manage the the right momentum during the
combat rather than just finding the
better weapon and the better weapon
because the enemy's Rises with you so
you need to have a better reference
that's why it's easier to us to connect
players even from different moments in
them in a story yeah awesome
well Audrey and Chris thank you so much
for joining us one more time you said
you have a release window correct when
can people will hope you get their hands
on us it's spring 2020 awesome well
thank you so much for joining we
appreciate it and congratulations on
showing more of it this week good luck
with the rest of the year and the launch
next year they're gonna be the rescue
get something clean you're watching here
thank you so much for joining today if
you're watching from home thank you for
joining we are gonna be here the rest of
the week with more interviews with some
creators tomorrow we have baldur's gate
3 which I'm super excited for thank you
so much for joining we will see you in
the morning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]